[Music]
we're at one at 12 o'clock not quite one
o'clock depending on what might be
another
time zone but let's let our chief
executive
get himself prepared
so um
important that we're all wearing our
mask i know joan you've got an exemption
so um
all right
all right just um
firstly uh you're right legion
uh firstly uh welcome to um this
extraordinary meeting
um i've got apologies from councillor
stewart who's unwell
councillor black is receiving his royal
honor which is great for him
and councillor duty uh is an apology as
well could i have someone move those
apologies back here for council
directors and seconded by councillor
williams i'll put that
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried
any conflicts of interest to be declared
right we've come to item three 3.1 the
covet 19 protection framework that's a
report in the name of our chief
executive we've also got liz and chris
with us so who's taking it is that you
taking the lead liz great
thanks
thank you mr mayor thank you councillors
so as mentioned uh chris and i will be
providing a summary of the report and
presenting it today on behalf of the
chief executive
so we're here to summarize key matters
facing the council and i'm going to
hopefully give a bit of a a pre-see
before you make your decision
so to give some background on the 18th
of october 2021
kavanaugh agreed to shift our approach
for managing the delta variant of coven
19 from an elimination strategy to an
approach based on minimization and
protection
and to use the kobe 19 protection
framework or the framework to give
effect to that new strategy
the strategy reflects that a different
approach is needed for delta focusing on
minimization
and reducing the impact of covid19 in
our communities
the canterbury dhb has achieved 91 of
the population is fully vaccinated
96 of the region is partially vaccinated
there was a press release issued by
council on the 2nd of december stating
the council will be delaying its
decision and that is the present for the
report today
so the framework introduces a new
flexible three-level approach to
managing covert 19 in the community
you have green where limited community
transmission is occurring and covert 19
case numbers are at levels that the
health system is able to manage
orange where the community transmission
is increasing and putting pressure on
our health system
and red the health system is facing an
unsustainable number of hospitalizations
and action is needed to protect our
vulnerable people
the framework has been designed to
provide greater freedom for vaccinated
people in our communities and to reduce
the burden on our public health
restrictions it is a targeted approach
and different elements will apply at
different levels and as council is
already aware our current region is
situated at an orange
being orange means that many general
settings still need to occur we still
need to keep accurate records and scan
qr codes masks are mandatory on flights
public transport taxis retail public
venues and are encouraged in other
facilities
public facilities are open with capacity
limits based on the one meter distancing
and this has been a change to the
previous alert levels
workplaces are open education is open
with public health measures in place
and with regards to the mandate order
and there are specified outdoor
community events which are allowed
if vaccine passes are used there are no
limits on hospitality gatherings events
close contact businesses and gyms
however vaccine passes are not used
hospitality must be contactless
gatherings can only have a maximum of 50
people based on one meter distancing and
close contact businesses include events
and gyms which are not able to operate
council need to consider health and
safety obligations as a pcbu and as
persons carrying out a business or
undertaking chief executives have an
obligation under the health and safety
at work act to maintain a workplace
which is free from harm so far as is
reasonably practicable
as part of this the chief executive has
had to undertake a risk assessment
across the organization to determine
what positions are required to be held
by vaccinated people so the organization
has completed such a risk assessment on
our aquatic centers and our libraries
and the risk assessment rating has
determined that they rate at a level
four which is considered to be a high
risk
when considering
applying vaccination passes to our
libraries and aquatic aquatic centres
there is an eight-step process which has
been issued from the government to help
us to understand whether we choose to
apply these passes or not
given the fact that we are considered to
be a public facility it is down to us to
make that determination
as part of our risk assessment process
we have considered a number of factors
and agencies who consider
requiring members of the public who are
accessing our premises where public
services are provided
the consideration of these factors
includes the need to ensure
accessibility of services the nature of
the services provided
our health and safety risk assessment
and vaccination policy and any
considerations under the new zealand
bill of rights act and the human rights
act including any takanga or
emphasization of physical presence that
applies in that regard
so as mentioned we have applied that
process it is staff's recommendation
that the aquatic facilities and our
libraries which includes ruatanifa and
the oxford library and service center
move to vaccination passports passes
effective from next week and i will take
the rest of the report as read
and hopefully to answer any questions
which council would like to ask
thanks liz chris do you want to add
anything
no that's that's one jim
thank you liz uh thank you worship i'll
just draw a councillor's attention to
page 21 of the agenda
which is part of the legal opinion from
simpson griezmann provided to
all local authorities and basically what
it says is
under the the current law it's
developing at pace
but it would be
a council would be unlikely to justify
mandatory vaccinations
across all aspects of its operations and
as of today's date so
that has had a bearing in terms of those
high-risk roles and the reason why we're
going for double vaccination at the
stage for those groups
thank you
any questions of colleagues
count so sorry
council barnett i'll look to
i'm not very good at looking at this
side council by the first father by
councillor redmond
thanks very much for your report liz and
chris um i just want to clarify what
happens with children particularly for
the aquatics facilities because that's a
very sort of gray area at the moment
particularly because they're then
talking about five to twelves eventually
being vaccinated um
for children under 14 are supposed to
always have a parent with them
so if a parent is vaccinated and a child
is 13 or 12 and is not dex the 13 are
not vaccinated do they have to they
still have to have the child vaccinated
yeah so any children over 12 um will
have to be vaccinated um and we do have
for instance school groups that come in
with children in a certain year where we
know that they're all over 12.
um our staff will um
[Music]
they can check to see whether a child is
12 but we will leave that up to their
discretion um depending um but that
you're right they have to have an adult
with them if they're 12 coming into the
facility so they would both have to be
checked
and so when the the 5 to 12 might come
in
will there be a
you think there's likely to be a time
period where there might be a bit of a
crossover while that's happening
um
i would i would hope that there is um
things change rapidly and we need to
respond to those changes the best we can
with the best information that we have
so we would be looking at what the
guidance is from the government and then
we would be making decisions
operationally around how we'd roll that
out at the time thank you
council redmond followed by council
atkinson
i thank you listen chris
this is quite an important matter for
residents have you considered
alternative
means of delivery of services to
unvaccinated people for example the
library i think previously we operated a
contactless system
um is that something we could uh
consider
yes so we absolutely have considered
those things so that you'll
you refer to the um i think we would
call them my book bags as opposed to my
food bags at the time when we were in
lockdown
so we will be operating those again and
we'll be making sure that we market
those to people so that they know
they're available and we can
have people that don't have vaccination
passes collect those from outside the
library we'll also continue to push our
e-resources which
through the lockdowns have become
extremely popular and we'll also have
library staff who are available on the
phone to assist people where they can
with the likes of technology issues um
and support that they might need that
they would usually get when they come
into the library
the pause is a little bit different as
you can as you can
imagine
uh cal stricken deputy murray
considering thank you mr mayor um
chris particularly around paulsbury as
well in our libraries what have we got
in place
to actually handle um
almost embarrassment if you like to
children
that may be excluded particularly if
they're in a class of children or
whatever and they're not vaccinated what
have we got in place to make sure that
they're not
seen as segregated or seen as
an embarrassing situation because
you know i mean you know how cruel
children can be to other children
unintentionally at their age but it
happens
so with school groups um and that's
probably uh where that's likely to um
potentially to be the case
we've the schools have already contacted
us and said
are we able to
provide you with the vaccination passes
without the kids having to walk through
and all show their passes
so we're working on ways in which we can
do that which
don't necessarily involve the kids
specifically so that
the school can actually sort out those
sort of difficulties before they
actually come so that we know that all
kids that are turning up from those
schools already are double vaccinated
before they come
when if people do arrive
and
they are with their parents for an as an
example and
they don't have a vaccination pass
we will have to at that time say look
i'm really really sorry um you can't
come into the pool the the the swimming
pools we are operationally it's a little
bit easier we have one point of access
where they have to swipe in already we
are able to
um load the um expiry date of their
vaccination pass on to their code so
that once it's actually loaded on once
they can just swipe through without
having to talk to anybody and that'll
let them through the gate and when that
expires they'll have to re-um they'll
tell us when the next expiry date is on
that vaccination pass
the library's
um a little bit different they can't do
that um it will just be site only so
that we're actually having a look at the
vaccination passes as they come in
um
and again making sure that we get that
messaging out through our facebook
through our
website so that people know
that if council make the decision today
they will be required to show that when
they enter
the questions
council brian
so i went to a crash at the kuiper
workers club two days ago
uh where a grocery intoxicated driver
drove into a fence
and i went back yesterday to get a
because i need a quote for reparations
in order for me to speak to the manager
of the kaiapoi workers club i had to
produce this
which is my vaccination pass
what's happening out here
that that's the concern i've got
absolutely
so with regards to our process
there are a number of stages that we do
need to go through so at the moment the
matter facing us
is about the public facility so aquatics
and libraries
uh later on today we will be looking at
socializing a draft policy to our
organisation with regards to the other
roles that we have also in the process
of risk assessing so those roles will
require a determination about
what level of risk they are and what we
choose to do as an organisation about
providing vaccine passes in certain
parts of our business and across certain
roles that hasn't occurred yet we are
not forced to do that as yet and it's
really important that we we make sure
that we look at every single role and
consider all of the alternative options
that are available to us and getting
gaining access to the building for
example will be something that we
consider as part of that policy
however the service centres at oxford
and at kaivoy
um are part of those buildings so by
proxy they will you would have to
show your past entering those buildings
to talk to the staff there
okay further questions
we've got a series of
recommendations
some are prepared to move
well i'll move it your second
uh robbie
um
it's an extraordinary
decision that we're faced with today
uh but this is an extraordinary
situation that not only we face as a
community
communities across our cu
our country
and also globally are facing
it's not like nothing else and we
are gathering more information as we go
through i i believe in the vaccination
program that the government have
instituted
and the protection that it brings to our
our communities
i've also heard from businesses that
they're welcoming the traffic light
system and it's important because it's
going to hopefully prevent lockdowns
as we know it and for
our businesses to be able to function in
our community to be able to uh
to be able to be about
uh and be able to be active throughout
that without being in constant lockdowns
as we as we have been facing i know our
businesses are welcoming this approach
and people in our community are also
expressing strong opinions
there are people definitely on both
sides of this conversation and i
definitely understand the position
that is put forward i've had really
strong feedback on both sides
fairly robust in some of the emails i've
received and the calls
of people who certainly have strong
opinions and i i fully understand that
and that's the absolute democratic right
in this country that we live in
but at the end of the day we've got to
make a decision here today
that protects our staff and our
community it would be helpful if there
were
a lot clearer guidelines
and that we aren't having to make uh
interpretations
about what the rules mean
but faced with the work that our staff
have done and i commend liz and chris
and the team and our chief executive for
the work that's been going on
to understand the position and also to
appreciate where what other councils are
doing as well
we are faced with the decision
and a recommendation here today it is
going to to curb some freedom for some
people
and i certainly
don't make this decision lightly today
but i don't see we have another decision
to make based on the information that's
presented
i do note that and
gee that there is further work with our
staff are doing as well um require
looking into vaccine
past requirements for the organisation
and that will be
subject to further consideration so
we're having this extraordinary meeting
today because our staff
need the certainty and we need to
provide that certainty to our community
uh so that's where we're faced today and
i'm supportive of the uh recommendations
um
let's remind me second of that uh with
counselor brian sorry yep thanks
i endorse your your comments miss mia
i've got four family members who are
employed by council
three of whom are in the aquatic
facilities uh they are vaccinated
however there is a very good friend of
ours who has chosen at this stage
hopefully she'll change her mind not to
get
vaccinated and she is brilliant at her
job
and i see that situation as tragic but
as you mentioned it's her democratic
right to choose not to
[Music]
hopefully hopefully because i know your
family wants her to get vaccinated she
will change your mind
the reality is
we're going to be faced with more
challenges as we go into the new year
and next year
and and i just sincerely hope that the
10 percent of the population not yet
vaccinated make the decision to get
vaccinated accepting that there will be
about 500 in our
new zealand community
who are unable to get
vaccinated
my concern is that perhaps we are not
going far enough
early enough but having said that i know
we've got very good staff who will be
monitoring the the situation because
they do have concerns
about people walking through this front
door out here
and going into our customer services
section
without being
vaccinated
you know in a another capacity
we're looking at
border controls
up north um
well in fact i'm not not even going to
go there because we've got priest prison
um but no i endorse and agree with the
recommendations
thank you uh councillor redmond
i'd like to move an amendment mr mayor
the addition
of clause h
which would read
that staff we are feasible and safe
implement alternative means of delivery
of services
to unvaccinated residents
okay well actually to be honest that's
what we're doing any of you know i'm
quite relaxed about incorporating that
into the into the motion is there a
disagreement with that
so
would you like to would you like to
speak to the overall motion that's
incorporating your suggestion if that's
incorporated mr mayor i'll certainly
speak to the motion um it's unfortunate
we're in the position of having to
consider these matters and it's not
something that any of us take lightly
we may have divisions within families of
people vaccinated and unvaccinated
but i've still come to the conclusion
that vaccination is the best and only
defense against coven
which has
influenced my
thoughts the rules are inconsistent i'm
planning on going camping at christmas
the camp doesn't require passes there
are shared community communal facilities
so you know it would be helpful if there
could be guidance in these areas
from the government
i do respect people's right to choose
however at the end of the day we have to
look at the greater good
and if we can provide an alternative
way of providing services to
unvaccinated people then i think that's
the best we can do in the circumstances
so
i'm in favor of the motion has
extended
council
yes it became quite clear looking at the
risk analysis that we have to do this to
protect our staff at work so this was a
legal requirement under the health and
safety act but it was not undertaken
lightly
we we strive as a council to provide
services to every resident in our
district no matter who they are what
beliefs they have
but this legislation has made it
impossible for us to continue at the
status quo
my concern i've got is that some of this
legislation contradicts other
legislation
because it's been done so quickly for
example a parent is not allowed to leave
a child unsupervised under 14
and so the 12 and 13 year olds kind of
get caught up in that
so if
they follow the vaccinations that is
generally of the parent and so you've
got you've got families which the adults
are vaccinated the children aren't quite
vaccinated yet so it is a very tricky
situation because you can't leave a 12
year old in a 13 year old on your own
so
there are going to be some anomalies
which we're going to have to face over
the next few months
which is going to make it tricky but at
the end of the day safety is paramount
there's a story in the newspaper today
about a young girl who went to a
birthday party at a restaurant and
caught the covert from an unvaccinated
person
at the event we can't have that happen
at a poll
when someone's at a pool there is no
protection and if they're unvaccinated
and more likely to pass it on
then we are putting all of those
children who come to our pools at risk
and i just i can't um
can't support that so i am i really
really respect the staff for being so
careful and taking the time to consider
this very very carefully but in the
interim hopefully it will change
um in the interim this is something
we're going to have to do i really
support councillor redmond's talk about
providing alternates of services
particularly with the library because
that library is very very important to
all families and all people in our
district so thank you very very much to
all the staff for putting in this extra
time and effort to make sure we look
after all the residents in our district
thanks councilman councillor deputy
americans
thank you mr mia i just um look i
support this again the same as everybody
else this is really
really hard to do
but
we're elected to make hard decisions
sometimes and this is one of those
situations we're in the reasoning for my
questioning is that
particularly in libraries children are
encouraged
to attend libraries
um
over the age of
12 by themselves because they're safe
places for which they need to visit
and there's a need as well as a want
and um
life can be cruel sometimes and actually
singling out
children of of a certain age and saying
well yep johnny you can come in but
peter you have to go home
there's a really difficult thing that
our staff are going to have to do
and i have huge sympathy and i i really
do implore that we do have the
mechanisms in place to handle that in an
extremely diplomatic manner and i trust
our staff
to do that but i just want to put it
across the table and and even pause when
you're getting over that 14 age group
you know um
you know high school students can be
pretty mean to each other at times we've
seen that in the past in many places and
if this is another
situation where people bullies choose to
be bullies this this can be exploited
for that so
i just want to reiterate that
you know we need to make sure that we
have mechanisms in place to deal with
that particular situation by itself
adults are
crueler than most people
to each other at times and
they have the
mechanisms to deal with it where
younger people
certainly
try but may not have those mechanisms so
i really want to reinforce that that we
make sure
that we're in the right place for those
people who
unfortunately are caught up in this like
everybody else
thank you thank you deputy mia and
further speakers
but just briefly in the right reply i
think the comments have been well stated
and i agreed we definitely agree with
the addition suggested by
put forward by
councillor redmond i think where we can
and as a staff indicated we should
definitely look at alternatives and we
showed that
through the times of covert how flexible
we were for our community and continue
to be i know our staff do that every day
they do an amazing job for us and they
will and for our community and i know
that they will do that and in terms of
our facilities as robbie councillor
brian mentioned
heard from
liz and chris that's under active
consideration and g does
uh cover that point
the campgrounds is an interesting one
that counts the redmond raised because
i've heard of other campgrounds where
they are requiring
vaccine certificates and in fact
being quite strict on that so what is
really required from the government is
very clear guidelines so that there's
less ambiguity and it's less open to
interpretation because it makes it
difficult for everyone
in that situation where you're having to
interpret what it should be whereas in
actual fact the traffic light system is
pretty clear
when you look at that and you go through
that system so
um
so the better that there can be guide
guidelines
where it can be
and i do urge the government to do that
so it makes it
into a degree i hate the word mandation
because we don't like it another context
but it does need to be a much clearer
system there so that our staff aren't
having to scramble around trying to
come up with what it means and how we
should interpret and look at the
difference there is between councils
right throughout the country because of
that
all right so with that i'm going to put
the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
i declare that carried
so i think i'm correct in saying that
our next meeting yes will be um on the
1st of february um so it's our last
formal council meeting of the year so
i'd like to wish you all a very merry
christmas uh
and i know that you're coming to my home
for a little bit of christmas cheer
later so i look forward to seeing you
from 4 30
with partners today
thank you everyone have a good rest
today thanks liz and chris and jim
cheers
[Music]
you